You know those nights
where you just want a little snack before you go to bed?
Today was one of those nights for me.
So I decided to make some potato chips.
Lately I've been obsessed with barbecue flavour,
so that's exactly what we're going for today.
Started by slicing my potatoes very thin
and then putting them in some ice water for about 30 minutes.
In the meantime, I made my barbecue seasoning by combining some paprika,
chili, brown sugar,
garlic powder, salt,
a little bit of citric acid,
not too much. Set that aside while I heated up my oil.
While that was heating up,
I made sure to dry all of my potato chips very well.
Once my oil reached about 325 degrees Fahrenheit,
I dropped my potatoes in it.
Did this in batches
and kept them moving around until they turned golden brown.
Once they were done,
I put them on some paper towel to soak up all the extra oil
while they were still hot.
I seasoned them in batches,
toss them in my seasoning
and then moved on to frying off my next batch.
I did about four batches
and then use the rest of my seasoning to toss my potatoes in
and they were done. These have been my new obsession
and lucky ended up having a bunch of them as well.